bienvenidos este es un vídeo para medir
ángulos usando el módulo de ángulos del
portal de khan academy este módulo fue
desarrollado por uno de nuestros
becarios y miren la verdad es que quedó
precioso y nos va a ayudar a medir
ángulos usando este transportador
virtual
le damos click y lo arrastramos para
llevarlo a medir el ángulo que nos
interesa y lo manejamos como si
tuviéramos un transportador real
ubicamos el centro del transportador en
el vértice donde se unen las dos líneas
que forman el ángulo más o menos así ahí
está y el lado de transportador que
tiene cero grados este de aquí lo voy a
mover de manera que coincida con uno de
los lados de el ángulo y ahora me voy a
fijar hacia donde apunta este otro lado
y aquí cae en el ángulo de 170 grados
vamos a ver si está bien escribimos aquí
la respuesta 170 comprobar respuesta y
si está bien una carita feliz
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
ahora tenemos este otro ángulo diferente
bueno hacemos lo mismo damos click
encima del transportador lo arrastramos
tratando de que coincida el centro con
el vértice del ángulo nos fijamos el
lado que tiene cero grados del
transportador le damos clic
le damos clic en la flechita y esto nos
va ayudar a girar lo de manera que en el
lado del ángulo un lado de este ángulo
coincida con esta línea de 0 grados y
ahora nos fijamos esta otra línea marca
pues 140
vamos a ver si está bien aunque parece
un poquito menos de 140 pero vamos a
escribir 140 grados
comprobar respuestas y estuvo bien muy
bien vamos a hacer otra
ok a este se ve interesante vamos a
tomarlo aquí de hecho casi no veo dónde
está la línea el vértice que une en
estas dos líneas que forman el ángulo
más o menos a estar aquí ahora lo nuevo
lo giro
ahí está pues qué creen este es un
ángulo de 180 grados casi no se nota es
como una línea de hecho es una línea
recta 180 grados comprobar respuesta sí
muy bien está bien ahora veamos otro y
aquí les voy a enseñar algo que no se
debe hacer tomar nuestro transportador
bueno esto sí se debe hacer más
colocamos en el vértice del ángulo es
tomar este de manera que por ejemplo yo
lo quiero poner en este lado pero no me
alcanza para medir hasta dónde está este
otro lado si yo quisiera medir este
ángulo que de hecho esto de aquí si es
un ángulo
la respuesta no va a ser correcta porque
no es el ángulo que me están pidiendo es
el ángulo más pequeño entonces tengo que
mover el transportador de manera que el
ángulo completo me quede dentro del
semicírculo del transportador y aquí veo
que me queda un ángulo de 40 grados
veamos 40 grados enter si muy bien
excelente y con esto terminamos este
vídeo de ejemplo de medición de ángulos